[Musik]
schwierige verhandlungen die
gewerkschaften fordern deutlich mehr
lohn für millionen beschäftigte im
öffentlichen dienst politisches
nachspiel im wirecard skandal
die opposition im bundestag will einen
untersuchungsausschuss streiken für den
neuanfang in belarus protestieren
diesmal schüler und studenten gegen die
regierung wieder gibt es festnahmen
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster guten abend willkommen bei
den nachrichten am dienstag mit sport
und norbert lehmann an meiner seite in
einem wunder hat doch vor mir
erzieherinnen müllwerker busfahrer
krankenschwestern sie arbeiten in corona
zeiten unter schwierigen bedingungen
besonders belastet das pflegepersonal in
den krankenhäusern
nach dem applaus der bevölkerung kämpfen
sie jetzt in den tarifverhandlungen um
mehr geld für die 2,5 millionen
beschäftigten im öffentlichen dienst von
bund und kommunen fordern die
gewerkschaften 4,8 prozent mehr lohn bzw
mindestens 150 euro mehr pro monat für
bezieher kleiner einkommen anti
klingbeil berichtet sie wollen mehr als
nur beifall in der korona zeit sie
wollen auch mehr lohn krankenpfleger
christian markus vom münchner klinikum
harlaching gehört dazu er ist eine der
wenigen nachwuchskräfte im
gesundheitsbereich
der altersdurchschnitt in den teams ist
sehr hoch wir haben viele leute die
kurzform renteneintritt sind und
nachwuchs steht und fällt mit guter
ausbildung mit guter bezahlung und mit
gutem lohn auch für holger hain
mitarbeiter des betriebshofes in
eichwalde ist das lob für mehrarbeit in
der krise nicht genug zum leben
zeitungskopf nicht steigen ja ich selber
habe drei kinder die haben auch ihre
wünsche und ja und sagen dieser job ist
auch nicht gerade körperlich leicht die
gemeinde kennerin ist zwiegespalten auf
der einen seite muss ich bin ich dafür
verantwortlich das geld reicht auf der
anderen seite ist es natürlich meine
mitarbeiter zu halten und ohne adäquate
bezahlung kann ich auch kein mitarbeiter
halten
schon im vorfeld der tarifverhandlungen
waren die kommunen zurückhaltend die
kassen sind leer
durch die korona krise fehlen die
gewerbesteuer ein
wir können nicht das verteilen was wir
nicht haben wir können es nicht über
kredite aufnehmen werde argumentiert der
öffentliche dienst hält gerade in der
korona pandemie das land zusammen und
höhere löhne seien gut für die
gesamtwirtschaftliche entwicklung vom
heutigen ausgang der verhandlungen
zeigen sich die gewerkschaften
enttäuscht auch wenn wir das faire
miteinander ausgetauscht haben gibt es
doch sehr unterschiedliche vorstellungen
dieser tarifrunde deutlich geworden sind
zum verhandlungsauftakt auch die zweite
runde wird nicht einfach gewerkschaften
und arbeitgeber sind auf
konfrontationskurs
schauen wir auf den arbeitsmarkt der
scheint sich nach dem corona schock zu
stabilisieren
die zahl der menschen in kurzarbeit geht
kontinuierlich zurück
arbeitslos gemeldet waren im august zwei
millionen 955 tausend menschen 45.000
mehr als im juli
diese entwicklung ist für das ende des
sommers allerdings üblich doch corona
hinterlässt spuren gegenüber dem vorjahr
gab es im august 636.000 arbeitslose
mehr
und in vielen branchen wie in der
luftfahrt geht das bangen weiter
ralf zimmermann von seefahrt berichtet
aus hamburg
seit ihrer ausbildung zur
flugzeugmechaniker arbeitet svenja
donner bei airbus finkenwerder wie viele
ihrer kolleginnen ist auch sie
verunsichert was die berufliche zukunft
bei europas größtem flugzeughersteller
angeht darüber gedanken machen müssen ob
wir unseren job eventuell verlieren
könnten 5000 stellen so das unternehmen
müssten in folge der krise in
deutschland davon allein 2200 hier nach
hamburg gestrichen werden
zahlen über die der betriebsrat noch
verhandeln will airbus schließt
betriebsbedingte kündigungen nicht aus
die größte sorge ist dass wir mit
unseren sozialpartnern dort sozusagen
dieses land kurzfristig schnell genug
hinbekommen um dann am ende
betriebsbedingte kündigungen auch
wirklich zu vermeiden die extreme
unsicherheit bei der
gesamtwirtschaftlichen entwicklung
verheißt aber insgesamt wenig positives
die luftfahrtindustrie ist natürlich
sehr stark betroffen weil im grunde der
luftverkehr jetzt auch zurückgefahren
wird vermutlich sich auch nicht
dauerhaft erholen wird das heißt wir
müssen davon ausgehen dass vielleicht 10
15 prozent fehlen wird so bleibt für
svenja donner und viele andere derzeit
nur hoffnung aber keinerlei sicherheit
also natürlich bin ich super angespannt
und auch meine gruppe wir sind alle
nervös und wissen nicht was jetzt auf
ihn zukommen
wie viele bei airbus letztlich gehen
müssen zeigt sich wenn am ende des
jahres der kündigungsschutz ausläuft für
die insolvente warenhauskette galeria
kaufhof ist das eine wichtige nachricht
die gläubiger haben auf einer
versammlung in essen dem sanierungsplan
zugestimmt damit ist die zerschlagung
des unternehmens vom tisch galeria
karstadt kaufhof war zuletzt durch die
korona schließungen in eine schwere
krise gehabt geraten
von den 172 filialen sollen knapp 50
geschlossen werden
mindestens 5000 mitarbeiter verlieren
laut verdi ihre jobs die wirtschaft in
deutschland erholt sich offenbar
schneller als gedacht die talsohle sei
durchschritten sagte wirtschaftsminister
er korrigierte seine konjunkturprognose
für dieses jahr auf jetzt minus 5,8
bisher war die regierung von minus 6,3
ausgegangen
dies wäre aber immer noch die der
schwerste einbruch der
nachkriegsgeschichte in der skandal um
wirecard beschäftigt jetzt einen
untersuchungsausschuss des bundestags
nach afd fdp und linken sind nun auch
die grünen dafür
wirecard soll jahrelang falsche bilanzen
vorgelegt haben milliarden verschwanden
unbemerkt von wirtschaftsprüfern und
finanzaufsicht die opposition will jetzt
klären wann die bundesregierung von den
machenschaften erfahren hat und was
dagegen unternommen wurde florian a
sie hatten es spannend gemacht oder
wollten das zumindest so wirken lassen
als der finanzausschuss eine
sondersitzung zu wirecard heute beendet
aber brauchen die grünen keine minute
bedenkzeit mehr
es gibt eindeutige hinweise auf
menschliche fehler auf systemische
defizite aber ja auch auf politische
fehler an der stelle und das
grundsätzlich aufzuarbeiten bietet sich
ein untersuchungsausschuss ein
linke und fdp hatten einen solchen
untersuchungsausschuss bereits gefordert
zusammen haben die drei fraktionen nun
auch ohne die afg mit der sie nicht
zusammenarbeiten wollen
die erforderliche stimmenanzahl mit dem
untersuchungsausschuss bekommt die
deutsche öffentlichkeit die möglichkeit
sich selbst eine meinung darüber zu
bilden
ob die regierung ob die behörden hier
ihrer verantwortung gerecht geworden
sind
die liste der behörden die bei wirecard
wohl nicht so genau hingeschaut haben
bekommt derweil einen neuen eintrag
so habe die sondersitzung heute gezeigt
dass es anfang 20 19
eine heiße spur gab die dann aber in
münchen beim landeskriminalamt und bei
der staatsanwaltschaft versandet ich sei
der hinweis kam vom zoll es ging um
geldwäsche auch ein thema für den
ausschuss der untersuchungsausschuss
steht vor einem spagat aufklärung in der
sache ist dringend erforderlich zu
zahlreichen die hinweise auf behörden
versagen und mangelnde politische
aufsicht im fall wirecard
doch zu groß ist im wahljahr vielleicht
auch die verlockung diesem ausschuss vor
allem für den wahlkampf zu nutzen
schon nächste woche könnte der bundestag
den untersuchungsausschuss formal
beschließen
turnusgemäß dürfte dann übrigens die afd
den vorsitz übernehmen
schauen wir auf die korona zahlen in
deutschland da setzt sich der trend der
letzten tage fort die gemeldeten
neuinfektionen gehen im 7 tages schnitt
leicht zurück und liegen jetzt bei 1.240
pro tag gestern betrug der wert 1260 der
berliner senat hat eine generelle masken
pflicht für größere demonstrationen
beschlossen
sie gilt künftig für versammlungen mit
mehr als 100 teilnehmern berlin reagiert
damit auf die ereignisse vom wochenende
als zehntausende gegen die korona
maßnahmen protestierten und viele sich
nicht an die abstandsregeln hätten
schauen wir auf den machtkampf in
belarus nun sind es die jungen leute aus
schulen und universitäten
die dem umstrittenen machthaber
lukaschenko die stirn bieten
zum schul und semesterstart drängen sie
in minsk trotz starker polizeipräsenz
auf die straße die opposition sucht auch
nach politischen wegen aus der krise für
begann berichtet
in belarus beginnt heute ein neues
schuljahr ein neues semester und wenn es
nach ihnen ginge auch bald eine neue ära
ohne präsident lukaschenko in minsk sind
schüler und studenten unterwegs zum
bildungsministerium
sie wollen ihre forderungen überreichen
wir wünschen uns ein land in dem du
herum laufen kannst du möchtest in dem
du sagen kannst was du möchtest und
dabei in sicherheit ist und weiß das
keiner dich und deine verwandten dafür
einschüchtert oder mitnimmt ihre
freundin olga fügt hinzu dass unser volk
erhört wird dass wir die regierung frei
wählen können das ist unser ziel
kurz nach diesem interview schritt der
demonstrationszug gewaltsam aufgelöst
auch andere protestgruppen treibt die
miliz auseinander
es kommt zu festnahmen während sein
sicherheitsapparat gegen jugendliche und
junge erwachsene vorgeht lässt sich
alexander lukaschenko beklatschen viel
kraft wünschen die damen dem langzeit
herrscher dass der ein
verfassungsreferendum ins spiel gebracht
hat hält oppositionsführerin kall es nie
koffer für ein ablenkungsmanöver
natürlich ist das ein versuch die
menschen zu beruhigen und zu besänftigen
ein versuch dass protest level zu senken
wir sind uns aber sicher dass das
belarussische folgen in den letzten 26
jahren verstanden hat man darf diesem
anführer nicht glauben
die opposition kündigt an eine neue
partei gründen zu wollen mehr
gemeinsam soll sie heißen sollte sie
registriert werden wäre es die erste
neue parteien belarus seit etwa 20
jahren in diesen minuten soll der us
präsident in kinos landen der
amerikanischen stadt in wisconsin die
beispielhaft für die zunehmenden
spannungen steht die tramps
regierungszeit prägen vor neun tagen
hatte dort ein weißer polizist einem
schwarzen jungen mann sieben mal in den
rücken geschossen
daraufhin kam es mehrfach zu schweren
zusammenstößen zwischen black lifes
meter demonstranten und bewaffneten
weißen bürgerwehren mit verletzten und
toten
frage an elmar theveßen in washington
immer der gouverneur von wisconsin hatte
trump eher abgeraten zu kommen um nicht
weiter öl ins feuer zu gießen nun kommt
er doch was ist von seinem besuch in
kanada zu erwarten
also der präsident wird sich als hüter
von recht und ordnung präsentieren
deswegen trifft er sich auch mit
polizisten aber auch mit ladenbesitzer
deren geschäfte bei den protesten schwer
beschädigt oder gar zerstört worden sind
aber sein mitgefühl ist dabei sehr
einseitig verteilt kein mitgefühl für
die familie von jacob black das ist der
mann der sieben mal in den rücken
geschossen wurde für durch die polizei
kein mitgefühl für die zwei menschen die
vor einer woche auf offener straße von
einem anhänger von donald trump einem
weißen rechtsextremisten erschossen
worden sind diese mutmaßlichen morde wie
die staatsanwaltschaft sie bezeichnet
rechtfertigt der präsident als mögliche
selbstverteidigung
ganz anders dagegen joe biden der hat
ganz klar jede art von gewalt verurteilt
bei einer pressekonferenz er sagt dass
randale und plünderungen keine proteste
sind sondern sie sind gesetzlosigkeit
die bestraft werden müssen
er sagt dass der amerikanische präsident
gift für die demokratie sei wirft ihm
vor er fachen die flammen noch an weil
er um jeden preis an der macht bleiben
wolle und jetzt befürchten viele
beobachter dass dieser besuch in katar
durch donald trump eben auch neue gewalt
auslösen könnte
vielen dank rt wissen nach washington es
ist ein besuch in angespannten zeiten
der chinesische außenminister yang he
ist zu gast in deutschland
dabei gibt es heftige kritik an china
wegen des vorgehens in hongkong zum
beispiel oder wegen der situation der
muslimischen uiguren eine million von
ihnen sollen in sogenannten
umerziehungslager sitzen und dann spitzt
sich der streit um taiwan zu das land
dass china als abtrünnige provinz
betrachtet andreas künast berichtet aus
berlin
es kann kein deutscher außenminister den
chinesischen treffen ohne nach hongkong
taiwan nach den uiguren zu fragen und es
kann kein chinesischer minister den
deutschen treffen ohne diese fragen als
einmischung zurückzuweisen
als minister mars minister wang in der
villa borsig am berliner stadtrand
begrüßt wissen beide dass sie sich
gegenseitig scharf kritisieren müssen
die frage ist wie scharf denn
deutschland gilt etwa den aktivisten aus
hongkong als leisetreter
seit mitte der 90er betreibt deutschland
eine politik wandel durch annäherung
aber wir sehen dass das nicht zu einem
demokratischeren und offeneren china
führt von der demonstration in berlins
innenstadt bekommt außenminister wang
nichts zu sehen hier stehen
exil-chinesen die um ihre angehörigen
bangen ob es stimmt dass china eine
million buchen in umerziehungslager
gefangen hält die bundesregierung würde
begrüßen wenn peking die fragen der welt
beantwortet und dies zum anlass nehmen
würde einer unabhängigen beobachter
mission der vereinten nationen zugang zu
den lagern zu gewähren wurde
egal ob hongkong oder die lage der
uiguren beides sind innerchinesische
angelegenheiten wir wollen keine
einmischung in die chinesische
gesellschaft dir kommandieren den
anderen staaten auch nicht herum was man
in berlin zu hören bekommt hat er zuvor
in rom paris und den haag gehört europas
china politik wird selbstbewusster nie
wieder
das ist die zentrale botschaft heute an
einem tag der an die düsterste zeit
deutschlands und europas erinnert
am ersten september 1939 überfiel das
naziregime polen und entfesselte damit
den zweiten weltkrieg deutsche truppen
rückten vorbrachten zerstörung leid und
tod
insgesamt starben im zweiten weltkrieg
rund sechs millionen polen darunter drei
millionen juden in berlin wird nun eine
gedenkstätte für die opfer gefordert
stefan r
burger berichtet gedenken an den
überfall auf polen am anhalter bahnhof
in berlin eine gedenkstätte oder ein
denkmal das daran erinnert hat die stadt
nicht deshalb fordert eine initiative
namhafter persönlichkeiten ein denkmal
für polnische opfer
polen braucht eine besondere besondere
zeichen des gedenkens erinnerung die
sich versetzen können drei millionen
polnische juden wurden in
konzentrationslagern ermordet
insgesamt starben sechs millionen polen
doch auch russen weißrussen und ukraine
sowie viele andere europäer ließen ihr
leben
werden die dann auch gedenkorte in der
hauptstadt fordern kritiker fürchten
eine nationalisierung des gedenkens
entscheiden muss der bundestag der
kompromissvorschlag sieht eine
gedenkstätte für polen und ein
dokumentationszentrum für alle
europäischen opfer vor
was besser wäre wäre ein museum eine
gedenk eine informations städte die
konzentriert information für
besucherinnen und besucher bietet aber
vielleicht auch auf diese symbolische
dimension des denkmals die ohnehin sehr
schwer einzulösen ist verzichtet ein
denkmal wurde heute morgen schon
eingeweiht das für die polnischen
befreier berlins des bezirks
charlottenburg-wilmersdorf josef koloss
mit ski veteran heute 98 war damals
dabei ich bin sehr glücklich darüber
dass ich hier sein kann und die
einweihung des denkmals persönlich
erleben darf
eine kleine geste die große lässt noch
auf sich warten
[Musik]
wir sind beim sport und bei den ort und
den us open in new york ja und da hat
deutschlands bester tennisspieler die
zweite runde erreicht alexander zürich
setzten sich gestern abend gegen den
südafrikaner kevin anderson durch und
feierte damit seinen ersten sieg nach
der korona pause die us-open geben sich
als carola freie zone auch zverev muss
mit maske ran nachdem lange offenen
match gegen den früheren us open
finalisten anderson unten im bild am
netz gelingt wäre ein frühes break im
dritten satz den er dann auch gewählt
daran habe ich jetzt sechs monate
gearbeitet am aufschlag und volley spiel
der franzose den ab er war vorab nach
einem positiven corona test
ausgeschlossen worden
sie wirft beschwerte sich von dem fall
erst aus den medien erfahren zu haben
gegen anderson kommt er mit 7 zu 6 5 7 6
2 und 7 zu 5 eine runde weiter die
familie ist diesmal nicht dabei nur
bruder micha grüßt per video
mehr geht nicht zur zeit rb leipzig
könnte als erster bundesliga-verein in
der neuen saison wieder vor zuschauern
spielen das örtliche gesundheitsamt hat
8500 fans beim spiel gegen mainz am 20
september zugelassen
die genehmigung ist abhängig vom
aktuellen infektionsgeschehen vor dem
ersten spieltag skifahrerin viktoria
rebensburg beendet überraschend ihre
karriere die 30 jährige begründete ihre
entscheidung damit dass sie nach ihrer
knieverletzung nicht mehr das top niveau
früherer zeiten erreichen könne
ihr größter erfolg olympiagold im
riesenslalom 2010 in vancouver war das
außerdem wir waren regensburg insgesamt
19 weltcup
so und wir gehen zur tour de france die
vierte etappe die erste bergankunft da
sind die anwärter auf den gesamtsieg
erstmals gefordert und einer der
tour-favoriten macht dann auch heute das
rennen primosch rob lipps zur wenigen
250 meter vor dem ziel die attacke und
ein kräftezehrender sprint um den
tagessieg den prima blitz vom team jumbo
wismar für sich entschied
nach der bergetappe auf 1800 meter vom
restaurant nach auswahl at sprintete
auch der gesamtführende schuljahr
phillipe um den tagessieg mit um das
gelbe trikot zu verteidigen am ende
wurde er fünfter vorjahres-vierte
emanuel buchmann der kurz vor der tour
noch schwer gestürzt war verloren 9
sekunden auf den gesamtführenden und
fiel in der gesamtwertung auf platz 17
zurück platz 17 uhr kleiner dämpfer für
die deutsche tour de france hoffnung dem
anderen buch man dann gehts ja es wird
etwas wärmer morgen aber regen ist auch
dabei die details hat gleich beim wetter
ist sind elli das war es von uns das
heute journal um viertel vor zehn mit
marietta slomka
wir sagen danke für ihr interesse und
verabschieden uns bis morgen schönen
abend noch
[Musik]
ein schöner abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter das tief über
polen das schiebt seine wolken
allmählich von osten her richtung
deutschland und so bekommen wir in der
nacht im norden den ersten regen ab der
zieht von nordosten her allmählich ins
land ansonsten ist es aber erst mal
trocken nur an den alpen da schaut es
ebenfalls an der donau bildet sich nebel
ganz im westen richtung emsland da ist
es teilweise sternenklar mit
temperaturen von 4 grad hier ziemlich
kalt im vogtland und 13 grad an der
ostsee morgen im tagesverlauf kommen die
wolken mit den schauern
von osten her über die elbe ja und blitz
und donner können auch dabei sein und es
kann auch mal kräftiger regnen an den
alpen gibt ebenfalls schauer ganz im
westen da sieht es sonniger aus mit ein
paar harmlosen wolken und die
temperaturen dort bis 22 grad im
vogtland ist es am kühlsten mit 15 grad
schauen wir auf die nächsten tage am
donnerstag gibt es im norden
deutschlands schauer ansonsten ist es
eher trocken 18 bis 23 grad am freitag
gehen die temperaturen deutlich nach
oben bis 28 grad und von westen her
ziehen schauer durch und auch am samstag
gibt es hauptsächlich im norden schauer
ein schöner abend